Вітаю, любі учні десятого
класу! Мене звати пан Вадим.
Я буду викладати у вас хімію.
Я не любила ходити в школу в дитинстві.
Я не прокидався так 9 років.
Сьогодні у вас перший урок. Тема
нашого першого уроку: «Спирти і феноли».
Почнемо з того, що ви вже
знали, що ви вже вивчали до цього.
Ви починаєте оксигеновмісні
сполуки, але пам’ятаєте, що
будь-яка органічна хімія
базується буквально на 2-3 елементах –
це карбон, гідроген та оксиген.
Тож, якщо ми знаємо,
що це такий конструктор,
коли у нас є карбон, від якого у нас є
чотири зв’язки, або чотири валентності,
ми можемо, за допомогою
цих чотирьох валентностей
від’єднувати ці наші
атоми, які нас цікавлять.
Конкретно у цьому випадку – це оксиген,
тому що це оксигеновмісна сполука.
У найпростішому випадку,
коли я під’єднаю хоча б один з оксигенів,
то я отримую
перший представник
оксигеновмісних сполук.
На що важливо подивитись,
що у нас з’явилась нова
група, яка до цього не існувала.
Такі групи, які до цього не
існували, називаються функціональні.
Їх є багато, потім пізніше
ми ще будемо їх вивчати,
але конкретно ця
називається гідроксильна.
Як не дивно, вона називається
так, тому що тут є гідроген та оксиген.
Гідроксильна група.
Вона буде об’єднувати
наші два класи сполук,
відповідно – це спирти і окремо феноли.
Розберемось зі спиртами.
Якщо ви подивитесь на цю структуру, то
ми можемо намалювати її трішки простішою,
для того щоб не розписуючи валентності,
отримати одразу перший спирт.
Як тільки ви бачите групу ОН,
яка сполучена з якимось карбоном,
неважливо, чи сполучений він у центрі
молекули, на краю молекули – це вже спирт,
вони так і називаються,
але ви ж можете мені
сказати, що спиртів багато.
Я можу взяти один Карбон,
а можу взяти два Карбони,
наприклад СН3,
який сполучиться ще з одним Карбоном.
Він сполучиться з гідроксильною групою.
Якщо валентність залишалась чотири,
то тут треба поставити два Гідрогени.
Це буде ще один представник спиртів,
відповідно, нам треба їх якось називати,
щоб розрізняти між собою.
Ви вже вивчили, що таке
алкани, відповідно пам’ятаєте,
що коли у вас є алкан з
одним Карбоном – метан,
алкан з двома Карбонами – етан,
з трьома карбонами –
пропан, з чотирма – бутан.
Далі за логікою, п’ять – пентан,
шість – гексан, сім – гептан і так далі…
Так от, спирти називаються
приблизно так само, єдине що ви робите –
ви додаєте в кінці
суфікс «-ол-».
Метанол,
є суфікс «-ол-».
Етанол –
Можливо, хтось із вас чув,
де етанол використовується?
- Етиловий спирт?
- Етиловий спирт! Чудово!
Всі знають про етиловий спирт!
Він використовується
в алкогольних напоях.
Звичайно, не тільки в алкогольних напоях,
але свою відомість він отримав саме цим.
Ми маємо розрізняти.
Ми користуємося такими
назвами як етиловий спирт,
це буде називатися метиловий спирт,
це назви, які несистематичні.
Це те, що людство
використовує, тому що їм зручно.
Але хімічна спільнота
використовує систематичні назви.
Чому саме так?
Тому що давайте я вам зараз намалюю
один спирт, одну молекулу, і ви побачите
в чому там конкретна проблема, і чому
нам треба придумувати якусь систему назв.
Давайте візьмемо не два
Карбони і не один, а три Карбони
і сполучимо їх між собою.
Моя група ОН може чіплятись на кінець,
а також моя група може
чіплятись по центру.
Що ви скажете?
Ми зараз уважно порахуємо
кількість Карбонів,
які в нас тут, відповідно, з’явились,
кількість Гідрогенів і так далі.
Тут, відповідно, СН3,
тут по одному гідрогену.
Давайте уважно порахуємо.
Скільки тут атомів Карбону?
- Три.
- Три, записуємо.
Скільки тут атомів оксигену?
-Вісім!
-Оксиген – це ОН,
ви сказали правильно про Гідрогени,
давайте їх запишемо C3Н8О.
Давайте зробимо ту те саме.
Скільки у вас Карбонів?
- Три.
- Скільки Гідрогенів?
- Вісім?
- Вісім.
Оксиген один.
Що ви мені скажете?
Формула у вас однакова,
але спирти різні:
структура різна, молекули різні.
Таке явище ви вже вивчали в
алканах, це називається «ізомерія»,
коли формула однакова,
але структури різні.
Там і хімічні властивості
різні, і фізичні властивості різні,
та нам потрібно їх якось
розрізняти на нашому рівні.
Як ми робимо?
Ми робимо наступне.
Оскільки в нас тут три Карбони,
то ми називаємо той алкан, який
відповідає трьом Карбонам – пропан.
Тут також пропан.
У кінці, ми маємо вказати
біля якого Карбону знаходиться
наша гідроксильна група.
Для цього нам потрібно
пронумерувати його: 1, 2, 3.
При тому, нумерую я
саме з того кінця, який
найближче до нашого Оксигену,
до нашої функціональної групи.
Вона головна, ми на неї «молимось».
Що, відповідно? Тут я можу
малювати хоч зліва, хоч справа –
немає різниці, молекула симетрична:
1, 2, 3.
Відповідно,
вкінці ми вказуємо,
що тут гідроксильна група
знаходиться біля першого Карбону
і це – пропан-1-ол.
Його можна назвати пропанол-1,
але сучасна номенклатура пропонує
використовувати саме цю назву,
а тут вона буде називатись – пропан-2-ол.
Таким чином, ми вирішили проблему
однакової формули, але різних структур.
Що стосується властивостей?
Які особливі властивості, в
принципі, є у будь-якої речовини?
Є хімічні властивості –
це те, як вони перетворюються та
взаємодіють з іншими речовинами.
Також фізичні властивості.
Як видумаєте, як виглядає спирт?
Це шматок мила, це газ, що це таке?
-У вигляді випаровування?
-Ну, як він виглядає?
Він виглядає як рідина.
Та ви правду сказали, що ви
завжди відчуваєте якийсь запах.
Ось цей запах є
практично у кожного спирту.
Він легко випаровується,
але, при цьому, не зовсім
зрозуміло, чому спирти є рідинами.
Якщо ви візьмете,
такий собі газ,
який називається бутан
С4Н10
і якщо ви візьмете метиловий спирт,
то ми можемо уважно порахувати,
з яких атомів він складається
та яка маса у цих атомів.
Ну, давайте:
тут у вас чотири Карбони.
У кожного атомна маса дванадцять.
Це ви чудово можете
знайти у таблиці Менделєєва.
Плюс десять Гідрогенів, у
кожного атомна маса по одиниці.
Як ви думаєте, скільки
важить ця одна молекула?
- П’ятдесят вісім?
- Так, правильно, п’ятдесят
вісім грамів на моль.
П’ятдесят вісім можем
залишити як відносну атомну масу.
Давайте порахуємо тут.
У вас є Карбон, у нього – дванадцять,
є чотири Гідрогени, у нього – чотири
і один Оксиген, у нього – шістнадцять.
Скільки у нас тут буде?
- Тридцять два.
От тут ми потрапляємо в парадокс.
Молекула важка, але – газ.
Оця молекула така легенька, практично
вдвічі менша, ніж ця, але вона вже рідина.
Метиловий спирт – справді рідина,
і виглядає він як прозора рідина зі
специфічним запахом спиртовим.
Ми не можемо розуміти отак
буквально чому важка молекула – газ,
а легка молекула вже є рідиною.
Тут з’являється одна особливість,
про яку потрібно розказати.
Пам’ятаєте, я казав про цю гідроксильну
групу, я казав, що вона якась унікальна.
Що ж в неї унікального?
Давайте з’ясуємо.
Оксиген,
який там знаходиться,
він на себе дуже сильно тягне електрони.
Будь-які елементи,
що знаходяться у правій частині нашої
таблиці люблять
на себе тягнути електрони.
Тож Оксиген у цього Гідоргену
буквально витягує електрони.
Електрони заряджені негативно,
відповідно, вони перебігли
сюди і утворився деякий
мінусовий заряд – дельта мінус.
Якщо вони перебігли звідси,
то тут вже нічого не залишилось і
з’явився плюсовий заряд – дельта плюс.
Добре, на цьому етапі, на маленькій
молекулі ми можемо розглянути,
але у вас спирт – це не одна
молекула, їх там дуже багато.
Тому, коли поруч
буде така сама молекула,
наприклад,
така сама молекула спирту.
Там теж існує така сама історія.
Тут десь дельта плюс,
тут – дельта мінус.
Бачите, що у вас плюси
і мінуси можуть робити?
Вони можуть притягуватись.
Навіть більше, тут
відбувається ще одна річ.
У Гідрогену настільки
сильно забирає електрони,
що в нього замість
заповненої орбіталі, лишається
дірка, або майже пустота.
Там не вистачає електронів.
Натомість в Оксигену –
цілих дві пари зайвих електронів.
Він може її подати сюди,
і при цьому утворити
ще додатковий зв'язок.
Такий зв'язок називається,
він позначається пунктиром,
такий зв'язок називається водневий.
Чому водневий?
Тому що Гідроген, або
Водень – він приймає
дуже важливу участь у
формуванні цього зв’язку.
Якщо цей водневий зв'язок існує,
в якій ще молекулі,
де є Оксиген і Гідроген
і формула якої Н2О,
де він ще може існувати?
Що це за речовина?
Вода! Він є в воді!
Тому саме вода, з масою вісімнадцять,
настільки простенька, настільки
маленька молекула, але вже є рідиною.
Що можна сказати?
Якщо у воді є водневі зв’язки,
та у нього є водневі
зв’язки, вони сполучаються.
Вони сполучаються саме за
допомогою водневих зав’язків.
Гаразд, забули про водневі зв’язки.
Що можна сказати,
якщо вони утворюються, то це значить в нас
буде якась взаємодія між спиртом і водою.
Це майже ніхто не помічає,
але якщо ви уважно зробите
домашній експеримент
і візьмете аптечний спирт,
наприклад 20 мл спирту,
і змішаєте з 20 мл води.
Ось тут у вас буде спирт…
-Буде 40 мл
-…Ось тут у вас буде вода.
Так і хочеться, насправді,
сказати, що тут буде 40 мл, але ні,
у вас буде менше, ніж 40 мл.
Через ті зв’язки вони
скупчуються і стискаються.
Це саме те, чим займався Менделєєв.
Це була його докторська.
Коли розповідають, що Менделєєв
відкрив горілку, то це не правда.
Горілка існувала ще у Київській
Русі, та ще, думаю, навіть до цього.
Але, що він зробив?
Він побачив, що максимальне стиснення –
це коли у вас пропорція 40% спирту
і 60% води.
Саме тому практично весь міцний алкоголь
має саме таку пропорцію, або близьку;
40% і 60%.
Відповідно, якщо в вас є
максимальне стискання,
об’єми маленькі – це для логістики краще.
Це перевозити набагато краще ніж
перевозити окремо спирт і окремо воду.
Саме це використовується
з фізичних властивостей.
Ми можемо закінчувати з
фізичними властивостями.
Що ж по хімії, з приводу
хімічних властивостей?
По-перше,
якщо розглядати групу ОН,
ця група вже зустрічалась і
в неорганічній хімії, і раніше.
Нас цікавить наступне.
Ось ця група ОН,
коли вона з кимось буде взаємодіяти,
вона буде рватись по цьому зв’язку
чи вона буде рватись по цьому зв’язку?
Якщо вона буде рватись
по цьому зв’язку,
то це щось схоже на ці основні
властивості, які ми вивчали в 8-му класі.
Якщо вона буде рватись по цьому зв’язку,
то це будуть кислотні властивості,
які ми вивчали в 8-му класі.
Давайте перевіримо ці властивості.
Ми візьмемо для цього спирт
і в цей спирт
зануримо невеличкий шматок
металу «Натрій».
Як ви думаєте, метал – це міцна річ?
Має бути,
але, насправді, не всі метали міцні.
Так от, деякі метали настільки м’які,
що їх можна різати кухонним ножем.
Зараз це перевіримо.
Я беру шматочок металу
і розрізаю.
Беру для цього
скальпель.
До речі, цей шар…
Бачите металеве блищання всередині?
Це – метал, буквально, метал Натрій.
До речі, він зберігається
під шаром керосину,
тому що він дуже активно
взаємодіє з киснем повітря
і після цього окислюється і, в
деяких випадках, може навіть
самозапалитись.
Я цей шматочок Натрію
занурюю у наш спирт.
Що пішло? Що спостерігаємо?
-Бульбашки.
- Бульбашки, виділяється якийсь газ.
Перевіряємо,
якщо я візьму кисень
і просто підпалю –
нічого не буде, тому що кисень
підтримує горіння, але не горить.
Якщо я візьму,
заберу цей газ.
До речі, як ви бачите, метал настільки
легкий, що навіть спливає на поверхню.
Бачили, у вас вогонь з’явився?
Ось цей вогонь, який з’явився,
свідчить про те, що
виділяється газ, який горить.
Конкретно цей газ називається Водень.
Він горить і при цьому спалахує.
У нашому випадку був етиловий
спирт, або етанол CH3CH2OH.
Я додав до нього Натрій.
Натрій, як і в будь-якій
кислоті, заміщує цей Гідроген.
Відповідно, у нас утворюється СН3-СН2-ОNа
і водень.
Горіння цього Водню ви
спостерігали, коли я підніс запальничку.
Тепер щодо сполук, які там утворилось?
Всередині утворилась
така сполука
(загальна назва цих
сполук – це алкоголяти) –
це алкоголят Натрію.
Так, смішне слово.
У конкретному випадку –
це називається «етаноат».
Чому етаноат,
тому що ми брали етиловий спирт,
тобто етанол, тому і назва наступна.
Брали б метиловий – був би метаноат,
брали б пропіловий – був би пропаноат
і так далі… Логіка зрозуміла.
Залишаємо.
Дивіться, в принципі, як ви
думаєте, спирт горить чи не горить?
- Горить.
- Горить,
чудово горить.
Ми можемо навіть це підтвердити.
Запалити деяку кількість спирту.
Подивіться, яким полум’ям він горить.
Бачите, він горить таким полум’ям,
що практично іноді навіть не видно.
Чому так відбувається?
Тому що коли у вас є сполуки
з малою кількістю Карбонів,
а там їх не багато – тільки два,
то він, зазвичай, горить синім кольором.
Наприклад, таким чином ви
можете контролювати якість
вашого природнього газу,
який є у вас вдома в газовій конфорці.
Якщо він горить синім кольором
– значить у вас гарний газ метан.
Якщо з’являється помаранчевий або жовтий
колір – значить, що у вас неякісний газ,
куди додають більш важкі вуглеводні.
Добре, ми чудово знаємо, що спирт
горить, ми можемо це спостерігати.
Як він згоряє, до чого?
Насправді, він як і будь-яка
органіка, покажімо на прикладі СН3ОН,
додаємо сюди кисень,
він згоряє до двох речовин,
практично це чисті речовини:
вуглекислий газ і вода.
Вашим завданням буде потім
урівняти ці рівняння вдома.
Добре, а чи можна
його не повністю згоряти?
Таким чином, щоб він не окислився
зовсім, а щоб зробив проміжну сполуку?
Так, ми можемо це зробити,
але нам потрібна мідна проволока.
Бачите, вона така мідна, ми її
очистили перед нашим дослідом.
Що ми з нею робимо?
Робимо ми з нею наступне:
ми її прогріваємо у вогні,
потім занурюємо у наш спирт.
- Шкода, що в нас у
школі не було таких штук.
Подивіться, як грають на
поверхні міді різні кольори.
На поверхні міді утворюється
зараз оксид міді – CuO.
Коли я цю розжарену
проволоку занурюю в спирт –
бачите, по-перше,
виділяються деякі бульбашки.
Це зрозуміло, тому що
ці бульбашки –
це просто кипіння спирту,
але ваша мідь стала чистою.
Хоча та мідь, яка не потрапила
в середину вашого спирту,
вона стала чорною.
Чому чорною? Тому що оксид міді CuO.
Що ж відбувається?
Оксид міді CuO
взаємодіє з нашим спиртом СН3СН2ОН,
і при цьому він робить наступне:
ось оцей Оксиген
забирає звідси зайві Гідрогени.
Утворюється вода,
а тут залишається
наступна молекула СН3СОН.
Як бачите з’явилась
нова функціональна група,
ми з вами її ще не вивчали.
Вона називається «альдегідна»
функціональна група.
Чому вона так називається?
Тому що тут прихована
деяка абревіатура: алкоголь (спирт)
і дегідроген – звідки
ви відібрали воду, відповідно.
Ми будемо вивчати їх на наступних уроках.
Обіцяю, там будуть яскраві гарні реакції,
але на сьогодні ми
можемо з нею закінчувати.
Які ще властивості спиртів?
Дивіться,
ми розглядали спирти,
коли в нас був тільки один атом Оксигену
і вони називались «одноатомні» спирти.
Один атом – одноатомні
спирти. Всюди логіка.
Ми можемо, наприклад, брати
два атоми Оксигену, три атоми Оксигену
і такі спирти називаються «багатоатомні».
Давайте наведемо якийсь приклад
багатоатомного спирту і подивимося,
що особливого в цих спиртах,
чого не було в одноатомних спиртах.
Насправді, властивості максимально схожі.
Вони теж горять, вони
також взаємодіють з Натрієм,
але є буквально одна реакція, яка ніколи
не відтворюється з одноатомними спиртами.
Зараз я вам намалював
структуру багатоатомного спирту,
де є цілих три функціональні групи ОН,
за систематичними
правилами воно буде називатись
«пропантриол».
Чому у нас три?
Тому що три гідроксильні групи.
Ви цей спирт знаєте під
більш відомою назвою – гліцерин
або гліцерол.
Дивіться… Для чого його
використовують, до речі, може хтось знає?
- Гліцерин? - Так. - Крем для рук.
- Крем для рук, в косметиці. Що
він робить? Він зволожує вашу шкіру.
Чому він це робить?
Три гідроксильні групи, водневий зв'язок,
вони на себе дуже тягнуть воду
і коли ви змащуєте вашу шкіру,
то вона завжди у вас буде зволожена водою.
Ми не будемо писати ті ж самі реакції,
що відбуваються з одноатомними спиртами,
але покажемо
особливості, які не були
в одноатомних спиртах.
Це якісна реакція на гліцерин.
Його можна виявити, наприклад, в
вашій косметиці, яка у вас є вдома.
Що нам для цього потрібно? Нам
потрібен, безпосередню, сам гліцерин.
Якщо взяти
мідний купорос,
додати його туди…
Поки що нічого не відбудеться.
Він навіть достатньо погано змішується
в перший етап з водою,
тому що він дуже важкий,
але насправді, з водою він
змішується у будь-яких пропорціях,
зараз практично повністю пішло змішування.
Додати туди лугу – NaOH.
В перший момент, як тільки я додаю луг,
утворюється осад.
CuOH2 – це якраз хімія восьмого класу.
Якщо я ще трішки додам цього лугу,
бачите, осад розчинився
і у вас утворився насичений синій колір.
Ось цей насичений колір – це і є якісна
реакція на будь-які багатоатомні спирти.
Що відбувається, ви
подивитесь у себе в підручнику,
тому що це достатньо складна реакція,
але в цілому,
якщо її робити правильно,
то можете знайти багатоатомні
спирти за допомогою цієї реакції
в косметиці або в будь-яких інших
виробах, де вони використовуються.
Закінчуємо зі спиртами і
переходимо до інших класів сполук,
які називаються «феноли».
Коли я вам зараз намалюю схемку
простого, найпершого і
найпростішого фенолу,
ви мені скажете, що це ж спирт.
Що там такого особливого?
Та сама функціональна
група, вона нікуди не ділась,
вона залишається у нас.
Єдине, що
там з‘являється щось таке цікаве,
яке ви вже вивчали, коли
проходили вуглеводні,
які називались «арени»
або ароматичні вуглеводні.
Тут з‘являється унікальна
ароматична система з кільцем.
Що ж там відбувається?
Ось ці електрони,
які на першому етапі можна представити
як подвійні зв’язки –
вони не знаходяться на місці,
вони починають
вештатись вздовж усієї молекули.
Вони просто, це називається
науково «делокалізуються»,
вони були конкретно десь у цьому місці,
а тепер навіть не знаєш де цей електрон
знаходиться – тут, чи тут, чи там.
Коли ці електрони ніколи не знаходяться на
місці, ви ніколи їх не знайдете «вдома».
Ця система хоче більше електронів
до себе, ще більше електронів.
Вона тягне на себе електрони.
Нагадую, коли ми
розглядали водневий зв‘язок,
я казав, що у Оксигену є
цілих дві зайві пари електронів,
і він ділиться.
Він готовий ділитись,
а через те що він готовий
ділитись, що відбувається?
Ось цей Гідроген залишається
без електронів зовсім,
його навіть ніхто не тримає, і
він дуже легко звідси виходить.
Тому ця система виявляє
абсолютно нові властивості.
Якщо в спирті,
для того щоб відібрати звідти Гідроген,
треба брати найактивніший Натрій.
Бачите, він в ряду
активності в перших рядах.
А тут вам навіть активних металів
не потрібно, можна просто взяти луг,
з яким взаємодіяли
одноатомні спирти і ваш фенол.
Ця сполука називається
фенол – буде з ним взаємодіяти.
Трошки про сам фенол.
Це – білий кристалічний порошок
із запахом, який всі чули.
Може ви зараз пригадаєте, чим пахне.
- Смачно?
- Не дуже.
Обережно, нюхайте ось так. - Взуттям?
- Може якимось взуттям, а може пластиком…
- Гумою?
- Гумою, пластиком.
- Конфіскат.
-Чому конфіскат, до речі?
Тому що він входить
до складу дуже неякісного
пластику і дуже неякісної резини.
Багато дітей говорять,
що він «гуашкою» пахне
і багато дітей пам‘ятають, що
він пахне іграшками з дитинства,
тому що вони не завжди робились якісними.
Ось цей фенол, я вам
казав, що це білий порошок,
але якщо ви уважно подивитесь
– він не білий, а рожевий.
Це відбувається через те, що кисень
який нас завжди оточує,
знаходиться у повітрі,
все-таки, взаємодіє з ним.
І робить деяку частину окисною,
і він через це стає рожевим.
Він достатньо легко плавиться.
Ми можемо на це подивитись.
При цьому він дуже
погано розчиняється у воді.
Для того, щоб його розчинити
у воді треба підібрати
гарні умови і, в принципі, було
б не погано його розплавити.
Коли ми його розчинимо у воді
або розплавимо,
то ми можемо спостерігати деякі явища.
Ви бачите, що він майже
миттєво почав плавитись.
Дуже токсична штука.
- Невже?
- Не дуже раджу, щоб вона колись
потрапляла на шкіру, бо залишає опіки.
- Як кислота?
- Як кислота, так.
Хоча це слабенька
кислота. В неї навіть є назва,
вона називається карболова кислота.
Це не систематична назва.
Бачите,
у вас при цьому відбулась реакція –
утворився той самий,
аналогічна історія зі спиртом,
коли ваш Гідроген замінився на Натрій.
Це вже фенолят Натрію.
Там були у вас алкоголяти,
а ця непрозора речовина –
це фенолят Натрію.
На нього теж є дуже якісна, гарна
реакція. Ми зараз її з вами відтворимо.
Що ми для цього зробимо?
Ми візьмемо деяку кількість, трошки
більше візьмемо, у нашому випадку, фенолу.
Зробимо з нього розчин,
наллємо води.
А ви дивилися серіал “Breaking Bad”?
Так.
- Як вам?
- Трошки брехали.
Там був окремий дослід,
ну як дослід, коли вони намагались
розчинити труп в кислоті плавиковій.
Вони показали, що кислота
проїла ванну і стелю – це все брехня.
Плавикова кислота дуже слабенька,
але в неї є одна особливість –
вона розчиняє скло і все.
Однак ні ванну, ні стелю,
ні трупи вона не розчиняє.
- А ось ця штука …
- Розчиняє?
-Так, NaOH розчиняє трупи, щоб ви знали.
- Але скло не розчиняє?
- Але скло не розчиняє.
Так от, якщо взяти і
зробити розчин фенолу і води
і додати туди невеличку кількість
заліза трьохвалентного,
солі FeCl3,
то при цьому утвориться
наступне забарвлення.
Бачите, темно-синє забарвлення,
іноді навіть стає чорним.
Зараз воно зникло, тому
що фенол був гарячий.
Так що я добавлю ще трішки
більше. Воно все одно з‘являється.
Ось це є якісна реакція на феноли.
Там утворюється складний комплекс.
Бачите, зараз вийшов навіть чорний.
Кольори приходять дуже швидко,
але найперший етап – це синій колір.
Так от, останнє про що хотілось
би на сьогодні розповісти,
коли ми закінчуємо з фізичними,
хімічними властивостями спиртів і фенолів,
треба розповісти про те, що всі знають:
де використовується етиловий спирт.
Він використовується при
виготовленні алкогольних напоїв.
Як це на нас впливає?
Звичайно, можна просто
сказати, що він впливає на нас
погано і на цьому завершити,
але трошки деталізації.
Не все так однозначно і легко.
Залежить, насправді, від дози і
від часу, коли ви його приймаєте.
Умовно кажучи, для
середньостатистичної людини
можна розділити дозу
на три різних рівні.
Давайте назвемо їх: мінімальний
рівень, або низька доза,
середня доза
і висока доза.
Коли ви приймаєте низьку дозу, яка
менша ніж ці 20 грам етилового спирту,
то спирт достатньо
швидко потрапляє в мозок.
Це така молекула, яка через
свої зв’язки проникає
в будь-які тканини, і в мозок вона
потрапляє достатньо швидко.
Вона активує збуджуючи рецептори.
У вас піднесений настрій,
це те, що роблять італійці, французи
– випивають вранці келих вина
і все, в принципі, чудово, і
день проходить ідеально.
Він активує, так звані, дофамінові центри,
і ви отримуєте деякий набір задоволення.
Середня доза активує
інші рецептори, зовсім інші.
Вони називаються гальмівні рецептори.
Гамма-аміномаслянокислотні
рецептори, якщо їх правильно називати.
Так от, коли ви приймаєте середню дозу
від двадцяти до сімдесяти
грам чистого спирту, то
ваш організм, мабуть, ви ще не
відчували, але дивились на інших людей,
які знаходяться в стадії
алкогольного сп‘яніння:
вони не координують свої
рухи, дуже повільно рухаються, їх
очі, наприклад, повільно
переходять з однією точки в іншу.
Тому що в них активувались
оці гальмівні рецептори.
Висока доза –
це більше сімдесяти грамів.
У вас активується зовсім інший тип
рецепторів, він називається «опіоїдний».
Ну, в принципі, ви
маєте розуміти, який тип наркотиків
діє на ці опіоїдні рецептори.
Це опій, це героїн.
Коли люди приймають високу дозу
вони отримують залежність, яка за
механізмом схожа на героїнову
залежність – це найстрашніша залежність.
Відповідно коли вам розповідають,
що у деяких, так звана «біла гарячка».
Вона чому виникає? Тому що
буквально виникає героїнова залежність.
І організм, який хоче
відтворити це відчуття,
він вам генерує видіння,
яке заставляє вас випивати більше спирту.
В цілому, ви маєте розуміти, що насправді
ми потрапили в дивну конфігурацію.
Формально, це – наркотик,
тому що він завжди,
особливо в середній та
високій дозах викликає
викликає деяку залежність,
особливо при регулярному сприйнятті,
особливо, якщо ви берете
високу дозу, а не інші.
Хоча, регулювання цього наркотику та
його обіг відбувається дуже по-різному.
Все, дякую за увагу!
Вадим – він не вчитель,
він просто мій друг,
який знає щось про тему,
яку він розповідає мені, і
він просто ділиться зі мною
інформацією, це дуже круто.
Він дуже крутий професіонал.
Відчувається, що в нього
прогресивне і сучасне мислення.
Мені дуже імпонують такі люди, тому мені
дуже сподобався урок.
За легендою, Менделєєв.
Ні, це не правда.
Спогади про неї є ще
за часів Київської Русі.
Він віднайшов цю формулу
і ця формула складається
із шістдесяти процентів води і сорока
відсотків спирту, якщо я пам‘ятаю.
Спирт горить синювато-блакитним кольором.
Помаранчевим кольором.
Якщо в ньому є якісь домішки, то
колір полум’я може змінюватись.
У фенолу запах... поганого взуття.
Сполучення фенолу входить до
складу неякісного взуття, наприклад.
П‘ятірка?
ЄЄє...
Все, я на інші уроки не йду.
Перша п‘ятірка, можна прогулювати інші.